bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vous
présente un nouveau concept né juste
avant que la vidéo commence je vous
rappelle quelques dates de tournée
pourquoi parce que n'oubliez pas que
c'est les dernières dates de la dernière
tournée après je ne reviendrai plus dans
les villes
je suis de 28 janvier à perpignan je
suis le 5 février à ludres du côté de
nancy ensuite je suis à chalon sur saône
ambérieu à côté de cannes à sanary à
marseille à bordeaux et à lyon et à
saint-etienne ya encore il reste encore
des villes et après vous vous dites oui
mais t'es pas passée chez que je suis
passé ou après tu dis oui mais c'est pas
encore complet vous avez le lien dans la
description
bon visionnage
salut je m'appelle fabien olicard et
dans cette série dans le cerveau je
visite le cerveau de gens que j'aime
bien et où je trouve ils ont un cerveau
intéressant il faudrait parler de ça et
voir ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur
aujourd'hui nous visitons le cerveau de
pierre cros à un humoriste qui est
devenue une vidéaste mais qui fait aussi
de l'humour en vidéo et plein de choses
vous le connaissez sûrement youtube
donc c'est parti on pénètre le cerveau
de pierre cros donc pierre l'idée c'est
de poser des questions qui sont en
rapport avec ton cerveau on est dans mon
père m'emmenait dans ton cerveau fait
bloquer ce que tu en penses
ces grands je pensais pas que j'étais
aussi rond on a un mobilier de
particuliers dans ton cerveau
on a quoi un mobilier assez particulier
ben c'est pas trop les htc corp alors
bougez me soit pour ceux plus c'est plus
chaleureux
en tout cas c'est forcément un souvenir
à toi tu vois je voulais mettre une
petite table ici ouais aussi et un coin
bar ben tu peux les faire apparaître
comme ça et comme ça bon je sais que
c'est relou tu sais que j'ai relu pour
monter on va commencer par son lobe
pariétal ballan s'est passé ici ouais ah
oui tu vas découvrir ton cerveau
d'accord ok c'est vous c'est passé juste
là ça c'est le lobe pariétal sager tes
sensations des émotions ce genre de
choses la question est quelle est la
sensation la plus extrême où la plus
intense que tu ai ressenti dans ta vie
sur scène je n'ai jamais trop stressé
j'ai le mestre c'est même moi je t'ai vu
je t'ai vu tout au long de ta carrière
dont son olympia
ouais et à l'olympia c'était juste fou
je vous raconte ça quand même la fin de
l'olympiade pierre là où tout le monde
prend son type d'énergie grosso modo
taper tout le monde pour qu'ils viennent
s'agréger toi sur scène est vraiment le
mec il a fait voilà bombardé merci
d'être version bonsoir le faux faux que
c'est limite s'il n'ya pas ouverte à
bière sur scène d'être dans les
penderies ion est allé en loge je les
teste c'était la royale ouais alors je
suis assez calme sur scène mais une fois
comme je le rappelle à la cigale choix
de rentrer sur scène et de mettre pas
rendu compte que c'était aussi grand
et d'arriver et d'avoir une sorte de
sensations de pas de stress le plus
d'abonnés qui montent d'un cran en se
disant moi en fait c'est je sais pas
1200 personnes 1005 et je croyais que
c'était une 500 places comme j'avais
déjà fait par le vent maintenant quand
j'ai pris l'avion de chasse avec c'était
le foot voilà la preuve que c'était
aussi fort c'est que je me suis évanoui
en tout cas là on regarde derrière toi
dans ta zone mémorielle ont vraiment
tout raté la nuit
il nous avait prévenus qu'en prenant un
looping à 900 km h et il avait dit que
le sang est pas le temps de diriger le
cerveau je prends un truc donc c'est un
pays où est ton cerveau le temps qui il
est dû sans perdre son contrôle et moi
avant de m'endormir je pensais à des
kebabs vraiment mais c'était une pensée
non voulue du coup ah ouais c'est celle
c'est justement ce qui tu es
c'était le naturel jara 5e avec vous
nous allons éteindre le lobe pariétal et
nous allons rentrer d'autant oui bien
sûr quand on voit un boy s'était
lui-même d'avant qu'après moi je
rebondis dotons réseau neuronal les
réseaux neuronaux par défaut c'est le
contrôle exécutif et le réseau de
prééminence ça c'est pour que ce soit
plus clair pour toi en gros sort et tu
décrire comment la créativité prend vie
dans ta tête pour trouver des vidéos
c'est simple tu regarde ce que font les
autres
ouais tu reprends oui ok on va rentrer
dedans alors il ya je pense qu'à
plusieurs trucs au début c'est monsieur
plus qu'à expliquer ça j'avais marqué et
en gros il va expliquer que au début ils
avaient du mal à écrire en étant
concentré en étant dans un bureau et moi
je n'avais pas non plus il fallait
absolument que je fasse autre chose donc
souvent c'était sous la douche que je
trouvais des idées ou sur le vélo sur le
scooter quand t'as quand à d'autres
choses qui me dérangent et tu arrives à
ne pas te concentrer que sur l'idée et
petit à petit quand même j'ai réussi
mais un peu comme il m'avait dit m'a dit
à force j'ai réussi à travailler au
bureau et me concentrer à me dire là
pendant une heure il faut chemin ville à
cake
je travaille pas mal par brique n'y a
encore je parle avec un pote de dunes
mini série qu'on avait écrit que j'avais
écrite l'an dernier et j'avais pas
écrire les dialogues j'avais créant des
briques de le personnage doit faire ça
et la scène doit finir comme ça mais peu
importe ce qui se dit au milieu c'était
logique de briques il faut que ça brille
clal elle respecte ce début cette fin
pour que c'est vrai que là elle lie avec
cela et qu'à la fin et toute une logique
d'un et j'adore ce genre d'écriture
justement où on se laisse beaucoup de
liberté mais il ya quand même des
logiques à respecter ok et sinon juste
dans ta créativité à toi quand tu écris
quel est ton point de départ qu'est ce
que tu cherches à trouver en premier est
ce que ces genres heureuse
ouais le bénin mais il ya aussi en vrai
est ce que ça va plaire aux gens ça doit
rendre ligne de compte ça c'est toujours
un problème dans ce qu'on fait nous en
vidéo parce que il ya ce qu'on aimerait
faire fondamentalement et après tu as
beau dire ouais faut faire les vidéos de
tes envies de faire oui mais s'il y a
que nous qui la regardons ça sert à rien
donc en fait comment comment attirer une
vidéo de vacances et sane exact c'est
pas mal bah moi je fais partie quand
même de ceux qui n'ont jamais trop dire
je fais les vidéos pour me faire plaisir
et peu importe si ça marche ou pas
depuis le début j'ai accepté de jouer le
jeu de on est sur internet si on veut
pas de vue on meurt dans six mois
c'est ça parce que c'est très cool de
faire des trucs par passion et
évidemment c'est le début tout mais il
faut que l'audience de motive il faut
que les commentaires il faut que les
retours que l'été soit suffisamment
matière parce que si c'est que si ça
reste faible c'est c'est très dur après
ça n'empêche que des fois tu vas voir
aussi les contenus tu dis mon
exceptionnellement je vais me faire
plaisir tant pis ça marche un peu moi
mais je tente quelque chose et
l'avantagent de sites internet c'est que
les gens le ressentent quand une
inconnue mais du plaisir dans un projet
ils sont derrière ils soutiennent et
c'est donc par contre oui c'est vrai que
dans le dans le lit des dents dans la
recherche d'idées de concepts j'inclus
toujours l'envi que ça marche l'envi que
tu as an les gens se disent h les
pagayeurs assez original je trouve
qu'une audience
c'est duke entre guillemets lcl se
façonne un peu comme toi tu sens et moi
mon idée c'est à dire si je m'enferme
parce qu'au début donc je faisais
beaucoup de vies au powerpoint si je
m'enferme là dedans je vais mettre dans
une spirale un peu négative un cercle
vicieux
j'avais pas envie d'être le mec au
pouvoir prenne toute ma vie même si dans
mon spectacle
enfin c'était à l'époque c'était je
gagnais ma vie plus avec le spectacle
avec les vidéos donc j'avais tout
intérêt à ce qu'on connaisse pour ça
mais je voulais quand même temps libéré
donc je me disais très vite il faut que
je propose d'autres choses et qu'on se
dise pareil fait que ça il sait faire
que mémoire épisodique
quel est ton plus vieux souvenirs en
rapport avec internet case à case à
rappel de cazin non c'était le logiciel
un peu peer to peer pour télécharger le
bulletin à c'était avant emule moi je
t'ai pas enfin ouais je sais pas moi je
me rappelle plus de casa mais c'était
c'était la même génération
moi je téléchargeais beaucoup à l'époque
soit des spectacles soient des trucs
genre morning live ou le dvd de jamel
les petits sketches way est en fait
c'était le début de youtube dailymotion
c'était avançant et tu télécharges et
des vieux de 3 4 minutes pour que les
maths et parce que ça passe à la télé en
bestof tous les deux ans ou fausse
acheter le dvd la consommation était
déjà celle là de télécharger une vidéo
de 4 5 minutes de se lamenter de la
médecine c'est des trucs de la passe et
les potes on regarde j'ai compilé tous
les merlans du morning live truqués et
j'ai fait concurrence à la vente de dvd
lobe temporal c'est qu'il ya une
différence entre les commentaires que
l'on lit sous les vidéos
est ce que les personnes peuvent te dire
dans la vraie vie le lobe temporal de
gère tout ce qui est positif
quelles sont les choses les plus
notables ou marrant to what the fuck que
tu as entendu sur toi pas lu mes comptes
a dit dans la vraie vie qu'est-ce qui
est le plus drôle ou le plus hot fuzz
compter dit dans le rugby en te voyant
un exemple très concret on m'a remercié
pour mes vidéos en tant que mamie twink
et donc j'ai fait une photo et j'ai
signé ma mie twinkle quelqu'un sur cette
saison moi j'ai fait ça avec
claudio capéo qui me ressemblent un peu
c'est vrai c'est que j'ai une photo je
crois de claudio capéo mon cerveau est
en fait on avait fait une course de
karting qu'est-ce que je suis fan de
karting depuis six mois et à karting qui
passe devant conservation et et on était
ensemble et il y avait des fans de
claudio capéo pas apparemment pas si
fans que ça on sort de nos cartes et
tout et lui il paraît moi je pars d'un
côté et les fans de claudio capéo qui
viennent leurs acquis 10 claudio ou par
une dédicace et c'est dur ça veut dire
je suis pas claudio la pierre cros
puisque je me dis six connecteurs
capello sait pas forcément mon audience
il me connaît pas forcément
je peux dire je suis pierre cros est nul
je suivrai je suis toujours kto je suis
aussi comme ça un mec méga fan méga fan
de mes vidéos qui regarde toutes mes
vidéos mais qui m'appelle squeeze à la
fin j'adore ce que vous faites avec ton
pote valentin benjamin traîne mais c'est
toujours marrant quand il ya un mec qui
aime loi qui dise à ses marottes et plus
beau en vrai qu'en vidéo après alors
j'ai jamais eu de comportement trop trop
gras ou trop trop méchant donc c'est
vrai que globalement les gens sous
quinze jours ça c'est déjà pas mal
bon il pleurait un peu et tu es tout
seul face à autant souvenir du coup
ouais voilà il n'est pas vraiment la
sicile et dans mon cerveau et d'autres
cerveaux voilà bien sûr s'énerve le
guardian tarder au polo ailleurs comme
il regarde nous servons bas il n'a
jamais vu ça là il découvre quelque
chose de toi qui l'a jamais est ce qu'on
pourra aller dans le sien après à séoul
mais regarde on y est maintenant et on
en ressort c'est des croquettes ou vu
que toutes les croquettes les parfaits
on passe du côté du lobe frontal
comment tu penses que vont évoluer les
vidéos dans le temps sur internet pas
dans le fond c'est pas le qu'est ce
qu'on va faire des vidéos comme les
discussions qui attendait mais la forme
est ce que tu penses que dans 5 10 30
ans tu penses que ça va bouger évoluer
dans la forme dans quand on concerne les
vidéos comment les fabriques pense que
la forme les formes originales type 360
vert et tout ça a jamais trop plu aux
gens ouais c'est ce que c'est dur ça
veut dire que ton devices un peu adapté
à sa que ton
de consommation et un peu adapté j'avais
fait une vidéo 360 une fois c'était d'un
ancien appart est en fait mon match
times donc le temps de visionnage de la
vidéo était en mauvais parce que tu
sentais que les gens se redonner un peu
mal à la tête que c'était pas adapté
donc je pense qu'on va quand même rester
sur du c'ur du trait deux des noms c'est
sur le c sur le format ce qu'on voit
déjà arriver aujourd'hui c'est les
vidéos de plus en plus longues
moi je trouve ça super ambitieux comme
un cri cailleteau sorte un truc de de 40
minutes et que et qu'au final quand tu
lances à sur une télé sur un
vidéoprojecteur et que tu es un peu posé
ça se regarde reste regarde bien et le
rythme est bon ouais donc c'est pas
c'est parce je pense que ça va ça va un
petit peu plus se mettre sur des device
de bonne qualité depuis j'ai commencé
les vidéos la consommation mobile a
énormément augmenté
il consomme moins sur ordinateur parce
que de toute façon les gens utilisent
moins alors des taux dans l'est dans les
tous de divertissement ils le disent
plus comme un outil de travail toujours
mais moins comme du divertissement mais
je pense qu'on va arriver après sur sur
vraiment du visionnage de vidéos sur bel
écran ou donc la qualité va devoir
monter parce qu'on va devoir tout ce
film héros 4/4 parce que tout le monde
aura été et 4k
kan d'avoir un petit peu encore plus se
professionnaliser moi je tourne pas été
très bon micro et des jeux l'écoutent
sur un système sont un peu cool ça
mauvais alors que c'est tout à fait
acceptable sur un ordi avec les haut
parleurs ou sur un téléphone et je pense
que ça on va le youtube heures au
créateur va s'en rendre compte
nazir attend ici à 50% des gens qui me
regardent sur un bel écran faut que et
un prêt non sur le sur le fort sur le
contenu je pense qu'on va revenir là sur
les prochaines années à cycle de fiction
qu'on avait un peu perdu en fait
internet a commencé avec du lait premier
youtuber c'était beaucoup de podcasts de
sketches écrits mais chip dans la
réalisation volontairement après il ya
une énorme réalisation avec les
générations golden à surveiller après on
est revenue sur du fait maison à thibaut
in shape exclusive avec un mix m et là
j'ai l'impression qu'on a un peu entre
les deux 2
on est dans du contenu pas très écrits
ont un contenu avec beaucoup d'humour
etc mais bien aimé bien réalisé avec des
moyens on va passer du côté de ta
fabrication de dopamine
c'est quoi déjà c'est ça c'est
exactement cette enquête il la remercie
donc au fond de toi tu le savais qu'est
ce qui te fait le plus plaisir dans ta
vie et comment tu peux atteindre la
sensation de hockey tout va bien tu vas
bon après d'être moi j'étais connaît
depuis 2010 legrand je crois que je n'ai
jamais vu autrement que dans cette
énergie là super content maintenant et
ça c'est super content fait ça c'est à
dire que au départ quand tu va analyser
les émotions de pierre quand tu le
rencontres tu dit attends je le fais
chier est content il apparaît en fait tu
t'aperçois que c'est un état de
neutralité permanente a raison je suis
assez aimée mais ça ça retour qu'on me
fait souvent en plus quand on va dans la
vie je suis jamais méga content de voir
quelqu'un même si quelqu'un que j'adore
je suis jamais énervé tu sais je suis
assez neutre dans mes émotions
après ça veut pas dire que dans mon
cerveau il se passe rien ça a toujours
été une façon de voir les choses de me
dire je me laisse pas submerger par mes
émotions pour pouvoir réagir le plus de
manière la plus et qui va rendre
toujours ok je sais pas si je m'explique
bien parce que aucun des mots ne voulait
dire que dans la vie on a vu voici bugs
derrière toi il est en train de bouffer
mon cerveau mais moi j'ai vu un kebab
passé je me suis pas tombé dans les
pommes c'est le signal j'ai toujours été
un peu entre guillemets même dans la vie
plutôt spectateur d'une discussion et
réagir sur ça c'est à dire que j'adore
une discussion à 3,4 où j'ai pas à la
mener mais je peux réagir vite un peu en
sniper comme un telle est la dernière
question elle concerne ton hippocampe ou
si les gens trop ta mémoire la question
c'est quelle est la chose la plus
complexe où la plus inutile que tu es en
mémoire en fait je me suis rendu compte
que tout le monde prenne et des savoirs
vraiment inutile tu vois moi pas donc
j'ai plein de décimales de pi vraiment
ça me sert à rien tu vas t'en vas quand
même fait un sketch ah ouais du coup je
gagne ma vie avec je veux je stocke pas
grand chose dans ma mémoire parquet
s'est bâti une avance en termes de clés
usb je suis assagi gars alors est ce que
tu sais faire quelque chose qui vraiment
de ça rien au quotidien les différentes
les différentes options que tu as pour
gagner au morpion
voilà enfin c'est pour placer un curseur
sur la vie ça et là comme tu es le
premier invité tel le curseur au plus
haut c'est à dire que c'est le plus gros
savoir il est il d'accord on met avoué
sur cette chaîne
les différentes options toit c'est des
pics marquion ouais on va vrai petit en
a fait un sketch est ce que pas inutile
c'est vrai un truc que complexe mais
forcément inutile du coup ben morpion
sais pas c'est pas inutile parce que si
des arts tu paries de l'argent avec un
ami et tu veux le battre
ouais tu sais le faire bon on a toujours
une utilité via la page
c'est dans ce cas là non non je connais
à peu près tout les toutes les castes de
fourmi qui existent au mans ces
passionnés d'insectes et sociaux ça ne
sert à rien dans mon spectacle du coup
pour que ça passe à quelques chiffres
exacts sur les fourmis c'est ce qu'a
fait max barde avec les ados indique
romain bien d'accord non mais moi je
trouve pas ça utile je suis ça y est ça
dénote plein de choses ça dénote le fait
que j'ai pas beaucoup d'avis déjà
rassurant les trois unités c'était sans
que c'est bon que tu vas hockey non mais
tu aussi le morpion ça me va merci
beaucoup pierre pour toutes ces réponses
et cette visite
l'idée de temps serge autant pris tu
reviens quand tu veux régulièrement du
coup mais pas trop on fait une bouffe
dans mon cerveau samedi prochain ok je
viens quand vous serez un peu alcoolisé
pour voir ce que ça donne ici vous
pouvez évidemment retrouver la chaîne de
pierre cros dans la description pour
aller voir ses vidéos et vous abonner si
vous le souhaitez leaké également cette
vidéo si ce concept vous plaît proposez
moi dans les commentaires le nom ou les
noms des prochains invités que vous
aimeriez avoir cela peut être de
n'importe quel univers
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à cette
chaîne la vienne également à très
bientôt ciao